today I'm going to talk about seven ways
to motivate yourself at work being an
entrepreneur is one of the hardest
things you're ever going to do in your
life and it can be hard to stay
motivated day in day out and get up and
hustle and get back to work driving
forward on your goal so today I'm going
to share with you seven different ways
that you can use to keep yourself
motivated
[Music]
number one is do what you love this
might sound obvious but if you look at
famous entrepreneurs the consistent
message over and over and over and over
again is that they love what they did
that they would do the work that they
were doing even if they weren't getting
paid to do it to do something that I
love doing I love building teams love
the process of solving the problems
that's how much love I have for this
thing that I do I love every minute of
it really love to do get involved in
things that you love you're so
passionate excited and in love with too
many entrepreneurs unfortunately don't
really deeply meaningfully love what
they do they're doing it because they
see an opportunity to do it because
they're friends that they can make a lot
of money they're doing it because you
know this magazine said it was a hot
opportunity or hot business to start
that's why a lot of people do get into
business they're just seeking the money
and if that's your only goal it's not
going to work out you're going to quit
as soon as it gets hard you need to be
doing work that you love that makes you
come alive that you're not just chasing
some target of being a millionaire but
you love the process of getting there
you don't see it as tons of insane hard
work that's going to kill you to get
there then you're going to be happy you
love the insane hard work you live for
the insane hard work if you don't have
that kind of love and commitment to the
work that you're doing then you will
quickly lose your motivation and you
won't be successful entrepreneur
number two is remind yourself of the
impact that you have one of the
challenges I found early on in my career
was I would go and meet with a bunch of
entrepreneurs and really help them
really inspire them and help change
their lives and then the next day I wake
up and would be gone like poof where did
that motivation go and I may not get my
next speaking gig or meet my next
entrepreneur for another week or another
month and there'd be a big lull in
between and so I had to remind myself
constantly of the work that I was doing
and how important it was one of the
things that really helped me was I made
a PowerPoint file of all the different
quotes that people left for me whether
it was at an event or they sent an email
saying thank you so much that I would
watch on a daily basis just to in the
morning remind myself of hey the work
that I'm doing is touching people's
lives and may not be a lot of people
with touching some people's lives and so
knowing that I was having an impact made
me want to do more and more and more now
I'm fortunate that I have my youtube
channel and you guys leave comments
every single day we get hundreds of
comments daily and so that's the easy
juice I look at those daily because that
keeps me fired up to let me know that
hey I'm not just waking up on another
day I'm waking up and I'm making a
difference and so I need to continue to
do that to continue to have an impact
so I'm spoiled now keep doing it I
really appreciate it but for those of
you who you know don't have that or just
getting started you can do what I did
you know write something and put it on
the wall and make a PowerPoint file of
the quotes from your clients from your
customers your machine that hate the
work that I'm doing is meaningful it's
changing people's lives
three has changed your environment it
can be really hard to do great things
when you're not surrounded by greatness
and that doesn't mean you have to go and
work at you know the top floor of some
downtown office to get the great
environment you can make your
environment better right now you know I
would think about where are you working
what's your workspace look like what's
on the walls around you what's on your
computer what's on the desktop
background what's on your phone are
there messages to remind you what's your
morning routine look like what are the
resources that you're feeding into your
head you know what videos are you
watching are you spending your time
watching you know prank videos are you
trying to fill your head with knowledge
that will help you become a better
person and a better entrepreneur all of
these things matter and if you made one
weekly change to improve your
environment you'll start seeing the
greater confidence in yourself the
greater momentum that you're building
for your business and you'll see a lot
more motivation for yourself because you
can't help you're in a motivated
environment right create that motivating
environment for yourself
and you'll be more motivated
number four is help a customer sometimes
we can get lost in the big picture
sometimes we can get frustrated that
we're not going fast enough that we're
not moving fast enough that we're not
hitting our goals fast enough we get
frustrated right we have this belief in
ourselves they go off and change the
world meanwhile you're struggling to you
know pay the bills and that can be
really hard that can be hard to stay
motivated when you feel like you're
talented and you're you're gifted you
can offer a lot of value and it's just
not working out one of the things that
really helped me continuously motivated
is just helping one customer helping a
customer out talking to them getting to
know their problems walking and fluid
giving them a solution making one person
feel happy makes you feel happy at least
it makes me feel happy knowing that I
talked to this person today and I gave
them a solution that's really going to
help them in their business or their
life that makes me feel good I'm riding
cloud 9 for the rest of the day even if
things might be falling apart all around
me knowing that I helped that one person
today made me feel good and continue to
motivate me for the rest of the day and
so try to help a customer on a regular
basis because it'll make you feel good
about the work that you're doing
[Music]
number five is do what you've been
putting off entrepreneurs like to build
lists right we like to build our list of
to do's and it seems like the to-do list
just just gets bigger and bigger and
bigger big we keep adding on our to-do
list and quite often there's something
on our to-do list that we need to get
done we've just been putting off we've
been putting it off because we're afraid
to do it it's too hard to do it might
get rejected it might not work and so it
just stays on that list week after week
month after month and no action gets
taken on it we're to be the greatest
entrepreneur you can be to be the best
version of yourself you need to push
through these fears and these limiting
personal beliefs and you need to do
those things that you are afraid of you
need to do that thing you've been
putting up because that's the thing that
can protect you really help explode your
business and when you when you've been
putting something off for a long time
and then you finally decide today is the
day I'm going to tackle it I'm going to
cross it off my list it's going to get
done and then you do it huh you feel so
good
you feel so energetic you feel so happy
and you're really motivated that you've
gotten nothing off then you start seeing
everything else start getting checked
off your list to do so do the thing that
you've been putting off and it can
spread a lot of motivation for you for
the rest of the day week month to keep
going
number six is take a break I know how
hard is to be an entrepreneur and you're
grinding and you're hustling and your
point everything you've got into it and
sometimes putting more work on the same
path is not the answer and sometimes to
discover that you need to step away you
need to step up if you've ever noticed
why you get so many great ideas when you
go on vacation or you get so many great
ideas when you're walking or playing a
sport or in the shower
why do you get some idea is it because
you're taking a break from the work now
obviously you need to do the work right
if you're just constantly breaking
you'll just come up with ideas never do
anything you need to do the work but
entrepreneurs sometimes just don't take
enough of a break and that doesn't mean
you need to go off on some three-month
vacation and totally disconnect from
everything maybe that's the answer but
it doesn't have to be you may not be
able to afford that or be in that
situation
taking a break could just be going for a
walk around the block walk into the
coffee shop going for a shower if you
feel stuck quite often the best solution
is to break and come back to it and
you'll get an answer if you just try to
plow through it often just yields more
frustration and less results so if
you're feeling not motivated you're
feeling a lack of progress take a break
go do something else
accomplish something else check out
something that's been on your personal
list for a while and doing that gives
you strength and motivation and momentum
that you can fuel back into your
business as well
and number seven is change your work so
I mentioned the first point about you
got to love what you do if you're
constantly finding yourself not
motivated not motivated you got to
constantly do all these things to try to
bump up your morale then maybe just
maybe you're in the wrong field maybe
you shouldn't be doing what you're doing
now
every entrepreneur's going to have hard
days hard weeks hard months you know
that it's a lot of hard times but you
have to have enough good there there has
to be enough that keeps you alive that
makes you want to keep doing this and if
you're just waking up every day totally
unmotivated then it might be time to
look in the mirror and say maybe this is
not the thing that I should be doing and
I think a lot of people don't give
themselves the opportunity to explore
enough a story that I like to tell is if
you think about the greatest hockey
player of all time somebody might say
Wayne Gretzky or the greatest basketball
player of all time you might see Michael
Jordan I would contest that the greatest
basketball player of all time is not
Michael Jordan here's basketball player
of all time you've never heard of him
because he never picked up a basketball
and so now he's a manager at a coffee
shop or he's a janitor or he's a
mechanic or he's a lawyer he's you know
nothing wrong with any potential fields
but he's living a life less than what he
could be he's living a life under his
true potential and so Michael Jordan is
now the greatest basketball player of
all time instead of this guy because he
never picked up a basketball because he
never explored enough to find what he
could be great at and so you want to
make sure you're spending the time doing
the activities that make you come alive
you need to enjoy the work and if you're
not getting it and you're constantly
unmotivated I look at maybe this isn't
the right path for me so those are my
seven ways to help you stay motivated at
work I'd love to know what you think
leaving the comments below which one was
your favorite which one you resonate
most with I'd also love to know if you
want to add to the list how do you stay
motivated at your work that I didn't
mention yet leave it in the comments
below I'm going to join the discussion
thank you guys so much for watching have
an amazing day continue to believe and
I'll see you soon